[Musique]
à l'occasion des journées européennes du
patrimoine la remise de prix du concours
régional de photographies monument de
beauté de l'océan indien ses dires il ya
là vous la dire un mot ce samedi 17
septembre
pour cette première édition 21
établissements de madagascar maurice
mayotte et la réunion sous lui 45
production photographique le concours
photographique c'est vraiment essayé de
vulgariser le patrimoine c'est à dire
qu'on a travaillé essentiellement sur
des aspects professionnels donc de
numérisation de descriptions l'image
maintenant on souhaite valoriser cette
image donc au delà l'aspect
professionnel c'est vraiment de la
diffusion désormais du patrimoine et
bien évidemment les jeunes publics sont
des publics cibles c'est pour ça qu'on a
lancé ce concours de photographie
régionale au niveau de l'océan indien à
travers la photographie
on permet à lons jeunes de regarder deux
de comprendre aussi de se questionner et
de regarder notre patrimoine et il ya eu
un travail qui a été fait par les
collégiens et qui nous a fait vraiment
découvrir à travers
leurs yeux
de jeunes
des
structures
patrimonial est vraiment superbement
bien photographier et ça c'est aussi à
travers un photographe et apprendre aux
jeunes à regarder ce qui les entoure
c'est le collège bohémienne titi de
mayotte qui a décroché la première place
avec son projet intitulé jours de fête
chez monsieur le gouverneur est
présente
les vainqueurs ont remporté un séjour
culturel du saumon dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]